ça va
bien mais votre tabouret j'ai mes
petites jambes qui bat dans le vide vous
avez quand même les pieds qui touche le
ca vas y
viens alors donc c'est vrai que michèle
bernier et aller auditionner au petit
théâtre de bouvard en 83 et elle a dit
d'ailleurs à la suite de son expérience
avec vous elle a dit deux ans et demi
d'éclats de rire et la liste est
formidable parce que grâce au petit
théâtre de bouvard on avait un nom connu
un visage reconnu et on était plus on
avait plus de comptes dans le rouge
quand vous avez été très important pour
elle c'est pour ça que suis content que
vous retrouviez ce soir oui je suis un
des hommes de sa vie et ça me réjouit
on avait calculé une fois avec les
copains que parce qu'on faisait
l'émission de télé on partait une fois
par semaine en province on jouait le
soir au théâtre et on avait calculé
qu'on faisait à peu près 18 heures
non mais on était inspiré j'ai passé de
bons moments avec michel dans ce moment
c'est pas là c'est un peu
chez rtl oui
c'est la première fois que les grosses
têtes me rend triste que on ne les
pratiquent depuis 24 ans avec un certain
bonheur et puis la bombe apps c'est
l'histoire des travées de d'un amour qui
se termine mais là on ça mais bien tous
les deux il a fallu qu'il arrive une
troisième personne alors j'explique à
nos amis téléspectateurs qui ont
peut-être pas tous lu la presse cette
semaine donc les grosses têtes qui a été
qualifié démission du siècle après un
sondage du parisien qui faisait quatre
points l'après-midi ce qui est et ce qui
était énorme 2011 7 d'auditeurs sur rtl
tous les jours depuis 24 ans alors vous
et quand vous avez créé l'émission au
bout d'un mois vous vouliez l'arrêter
parce que ça vous avouer ça va lâcher
c'était pas du tout le délire que c'est
devenu aujourd'hui c'était d'abord
uniquement culturel ensuite il y avait
pas de public doit qui avait pas de
fronton pour renvoyer la balle et en
matière de comics ça rend très difficile
c'est sur ce jeu alors aujourd'hui bon
vous êtes viré on peut le dire c'est pas
l'amour est un peu triviale mais bon ça
nous est arrivé à tous après faire
lourder parce que nous on ne s'est pas
fait légèrement
vous dites en parlant du nouveau patron
des programmes de rtl qui a remplacé
philippe labro qui est peut-être parti
d'ailleurs pour pas avoir à faire ça et
d'avoir du sang sur les mains ou dit en
parlant de lui stéphane duhamel et son
entourage se sont comportés comme des
gougnafiers quelle est votre définition
du goût niasse y est je crois que c'est
un homme sans coeur et sans éducation
oui bon c'est tout ça suffit bah oui
j'y vais pour l'hiver alors la raison de
votre votre éviction des grosses têtes
c'est le rajeunissement à cause de la
mais la fameuse ménagère de lannoy 50
l'aménager fameuse méfiez vous en êtes
vous rattrapera j'en suis sûr eh bien
oui et alors là il ya un discours quand
même qui est extrêmement risqué de la
part de la direction de la station
issa revient à dire à des auditeurs qui
sont fidèles depuis des années et qui
sont des gens merveilleux attachés à
leur station comme on est attaché à sa
famille vous êtes trop vieux cassez vous
ouais hein ouais c'est ça c'est très dur
de très délicat admettez qui prennent ce
discours à la lettre un et qui se
suicident tous imaginé qu'ils aient des
suicides collectifs d'auditeurs d'rtl
dans la valise s'apprête fassiez la
valise m'attend mais c'est que fabrice
aussi un oui oui mais bon c'est la
valise pour tout le monde
la maryse une certaine
dites moi mais alors c'est vrai que ces
deux là même qui l'avait remplacé à ça
je ne sais pas c'est un problème de
direction et je suis pas directeur parce
que si j'étais directeur je me serais
garde
alors donc on annonce sur la tl
l'arrivée de laurent gerra bon allez
c'est bien ça voilà de marc olivier
fogiel qui vient de chez moins bien de
canal+ pourquoi vous dites que c'est
moins bien parce que je n'aime pas
ah oui d'accord c'est bovard déjà et il
n'avait pas sa langue dans sa parcelle
que
j'étais né sous le signe du sagittaire
maintenant c'est la balance
[Musique]
alors quoi vous dites quand même
philippe bouvard rendez-vous au prochain
sondage parce que c'est vrai que l'après
midi risque même d'avoir un trou là
parce que vous étiez très très loin de
s'asseoir plus mon problème - alors que
jusqu'à présent tous les trois mois je
guettais les sondages avec il est
toujours excellent oui oui oui il y
avait une petite main s'il ya trois ans
frappée en allant plus vers l'actualité
et on veut même pas vous reprocher de
pas vous ne vous renouveler parce que
vous aviez décidé d'aller plus vers
l'actualité de faire des choses plus en
en liaison avec l'info quoi oui c'était
d'ailleurs pas la solution de facilité
parce que là on travaille comme disent
les industriels en flux tendu les tordus
m'en parlez pas
et à partir d'un certain âge c'est pas
facile
et
qu'avant quand c'était totalement
intemporel j'avais six semaines de
réserve je pouvais partir en vacances
n'a remarqué vous
voyez aussi beaucoup de pub ça leur
apporter du pognon votre émission parce
qu'elle est je veux dire que les grosses
têtes constitue une excellente
plateforme publicitaire puisque on est à
saturation sur ce plan là enfin c'est
déjà du passé et terry parce que quand
on prend des taxis l'après midi
qu'est-ce qu'on va écouter maintenant
dans les taxis l'après-midi
moi il n'est pas interdit ja derrière
d'aller ailleurs oui j'ai même un
encouragement et puis on
pourrait dire que c'est votre physique
que vous dites toute façon le physique
en radio que ça changerait en rien du
tout ça la voir je te donne à la voix
est excellente et la voix de philippe
bouvard alors vous dites vous aviez
déclaré quand même il ya quelques années
un jour mon refus de vieillir sera
pathétique c'est à dire que est-ce que
voilà est-ce que finalement au-delà de
aux dates et c'est je crois vous avez
bien fait de m'inviter cette semaine
c'est encore passable mais le mois
prochain on va passer une question
importante une question difficile madame
buffet
le chant
dont vous avez fait une question
importante vous avez fait une carrière
multimédia incroyable on pas tout citer
parce que sinon on sera encore là deux
heures du matin enfin une légende
bouvard l'autodidacte
jamais à l'abri d'être autocritique
moraliste boulimique boulimique de
travail boulimique d'argent vivent bien
la limousine bureau les ferrari la
piscine problèmes d'argent problèmes
avec le fisc problème avec les casinos
vous avez été obligé de vous faire
interdire de casino à la sortie
tellement ça vous coûter cher et puis on
sentait toujours chez vous une espèce de
une espèce de figure
est ce que tout ça finalement non mais
c'est de cette espèce de santé toujours
chez vous malgré votre succès vous dit
tout le temps oui je travaille beaucoup
c'est une fuite en avant
je me suis longtemps à hisser votre côté
françois nourissier d'ailleurs j'ai
toujours voulu être connue pour autre
chose que qu'un animateur
est ce que finalement maintenant et
c'est le but de ma question est ce que
maintenant vous avez pas avoir le temps
de faire ce que vous avez passé jusqu'à
maintenant
j'ai raté un peu ma vie j'aurai m
petites soeurs des pauvres
grand frère des riches et bien c'est
bien aussi un petit vous auriez pu
excuse n'est pas avoir le temps d'écrire
maintenant si bien sûr mais je l'avais
aussi j'ai quand même public a requis 40
lits m'arrête 40 libre ouais d'ailleurs
si on va parler du dernier
à
vous faites pas vous de saint louis
vous non même sur mon dos
publiez votre journal c'est le deuxième
tome dans la tradition un peu d diariste
jules renard paul léautaud le nom est
vilain mais la chose de terrible s'est
passé par
istres
oui non vous êtes un peu à nantes
homologue de la société française quoi c
j'aime bien je retiens le sua la fois
entomologues de la société française et
spéléo de moi même oui vous dites à 30
ans j'étais persuadé de faire une
carrière littéraire et de mourir jeune
et j'aurai tout raté
vous avez fait une carrière littéraire
est-ce que se vendent des livres qui
sont pas toujours des livres mais des
produits de librairie c'est une carrière
littéraire alors maintenant j'écris ce
que j'ai envie de voir page 16 vous
dites j'ai dû choisir entre la notoriété
dispensés ça rejoint ce qu'en disait
entre l'auteur était dispensée par le
grand public et la considération
prodigués par quelques esprits
distinguer le grand public distribuer
plus d'argent que les esprits distinguer
c'est tout votre problème ça finalement
alors lui même les livres c'est quand
même dans l'ellipse qui normalement
devrait être sacré vous êtes laissé
reggae de l'argent je voulais pas que
mes éditeurs ont peur de trop ouais et
alors il des formules très très bouvard
une vie on fait le con jusqu'au moment
où on fait le mort un jeu prendrait la
direction des cimetières avant d'avoir
trouvé le sens de la vie
c'est définitif c'est bien écrit sur les
femmes vous dites page 122 la femme
idéale ça c'est en dire un peu du guitry
la femme idéale c'est celle qui laisse à
l'homme le dernier mot en sachant
qu'elle pourrait en ajouter encore un
autre nom mais les femmes sont
formidables parce qu'elles sont beaucoup
plus brillantes et subtile que nous et
elle nous laisse imaginer le contraire
on est sympa en parlant de votre votre
âge vous dites je suis innocente victime
de l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie
au moyen-âge aurait jamais eu le temps
de tromper ma femme
c'est vrai on mourait à 40 ans et même
avant bon on trompe pas sa femme on
faisait pas faillite on se fâche est pas
avec ses amis bon on n'était pas lourdes
et de
40 ans vous soyez toujours dit
pour rester sur le même sujet j'ai écrit
ça en décembre ce que c'est un journal
je serai dont je ne me lasse pas oui
journal 97 2000 donc en décembre 98 vous
écriviez page 149 les licenciements et
les mutations dans le monde des affaires
et des médias on doit renouveler ce qui
se renouvelle pas oui oui oui oui oui
c'est pour ça que vous êtes renouvelé
moi je me suis en oublie il ya deux ans
alors peut-être que j'entre pas dans ce
champ là mais bon je suis quand même
toujours moi-même avec la déformation
d'esprit qu'on me connaît là mais voit
un peu gras seyante et je pourrai pas
être un autre alors peut-être que
effectivement il faut renouveler c'est
le monde c'est le mot clé le jeunisme
alors une fois j'ai interviewé il ya
quelques années vous m'aviez cité une
phrase de heartbeat cheval qui disait
quand un journaliste interviews de
journalistes c'est comme quand on danse
avec sa soeur
parce qu'il m'arrive de citer les mots
deux autres gros sous et je cite mes
sources en tout les gars en l'occurrence
c'est vrai alors donc
je vais pas vous interviewez vous allez
faire vous savez quand vous êtes un très
bon interviewer vous êtes un de mes
maîtres benji est mon maître quand
j'étais petit il ya très très longtemps
un vous étiez vous auto interview
c'est sûr
posez vous des questions et réponses
daisy à la première question que je me
pose c'est pourquoi dire du mal de moi
ouais bon bain parce que je suis sûr que
je ne me ferais jamais de procès
j'ai envie de me demander qui
auriez-vous aimé être et là je répond
sans hésiter un grand brun avec un polo
noir
question alors plus angoissante quel est
le désagrément d'être philippe bouvard
et bien je suis condamné à vivre jusqu'à
la fin avec quelqu un qu autrement
j'aurais sûrement penserait quand
j'aurai aussi envie de me demander ce
que je reproche aux femmes eh bien je
reproche aux femmes ce que drieu la
rochelle
reprocher aux femmes qu'ils avaient aimé
c'est à dire d'être assez peu exigentes
pour se contenter de moi
la question qui généralement vient à la
fin d'une interview vous bien menée et
la voter fabuleuse affaire de goût et
bien c'est une idée mieux que j'ai fait
et si c'était à refaire oui avant
et bien j'irai chez lagaf le dialogue
est plus facile
merci c'est la première fois que je
tentais l'expérience de l'auto interview
avec vous je peux pas me tromper merci
beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu